un día de contrastes el evento deportivo
el super bowl saca a relucir realidades
dispares de la ciudad que los ángeles la
cocina de este restaurante no parado en
semanas y todo el personal se prepara
para recibir a los aficionados
específicamente el superbowl atrae una
nueva ola de personas que vienen de la
ciudad de fuera de la ciudad fuera del
estado algunas personas hablé con un par
que son de fuera del país se espera que
el sector gastronómico y el hotelero se
vean beneficiados por el partido que
enfrentará a los ángeles rams contra los
cincinnati bengals se prevé que 150 mil
personas lleguen a la ciudad las
autoridades calculan que le dejara 477
millones de dólares una afluencia masiva
que todos quieren aprovechar
tenemos cuatro lugares de
estacionamiento disponibles para esto
para los juegos pasados los alquilamos
por 50 dólares uno de ellos lo hicimos
por cien en el último juego
sin embargo la experiencia del super
bowl no se expresa el lucro para todos
una semana tras la policía desalojó a
más de 50 personas que tenían sus carpas
en una avenida cerca del estadio donde
se llevara a cabo el evento
debido al superbowl porque todo ha
estado así durante unos dos o tres años
había montañas de todo tipo de
desperdicios así de altas
pero llegó el superbowl y vinieron y nos
echaron
aunque no los culpo porque supone dinero
para la ciudad
las organizaciones civiles calculan que
90.000 personas estaban sin hogar en los
ángeles en 2021 una situación olvidada
por muchos durante el tiempo que duró el
partido